Das sind noch Wildschweine und wir
sperren sie in diesen Rahmen ein.
Das ist ein Armutszeugnis wenn ich
meinen Kindern erklären muss,
warum wir die Schweine
so einschliessen.
Nicht mehr lange, Mädels.
Ein Schwein, das Schwein sein darf,
hat wirklich Schwein:
Mit der Schnauze in der Erde wühlen,
über eine Wiese rennen.
Von den 1,4 Mio. Schweizer Schweinen
dürfen das nur wenige.
Dieser Film erzählt
vom Schweinemäster Oliver Hess
und seiner Familie.
Von seiner Vision, den Tieren trotz
Massenhaltung möglichst viel Auslauf,
frische Luft und v.a. Würde zu geben.
Von einem Schweinemäster,
der eine Tierfabrik kaufte,
um so die Schweinehaltung
zu revolutionieren.
Vier Jahre
waren wir mit der Kamera dabei.
Vier Jahre, in denen
einiges anders kam als erwartet.
Unsere Geschichte
beginnt im November 2015.
Die wenigen Wochen alten Ferkel
kämpfen um ihr Futter.
Ein ganz gewöhnlicher Morgen
im luzernischen Mosen,
im Stall
von Oliver, Esther und Anouk Hess.
Gut so, gehen wir misten.
- Okay.
Ho, ho, ho!
Der Schweinestall
ist ein Grossbetrieb:
1'800 Mastschweine pro Jahr,
200 Muttersäue.
Den Hof hat Familie Hess
2012 gekauft, mit einem Darlehen.
Hey, hey! Hier sehen wir sie jetzt,
wie noch am Säugen sind.
Ich bin es.
Das Mami
ist beim Säugen eingeschlafen.
Als du zum ersten Mal vor drei Jahren
hier hereingekommen bist,
was hast du gedacht?
Ich schaue diesen Tieren
heute noch in die Augen.
Wir konnten ja
noch nicht sehr viel bewegen,
aber in diesem Stall
schon ein wenig.
Ich habe die Tiere angeschaut
und hatte das Gefühl,
dass ich etwas für sie tun muss.
So wollte ich das nicht akzeptieren.
Wir hatten aber ein Jahr,
bis wir die Schädlinge einigermassen
draussen hatten: Mäuse, Ratten.
Wir haben eineinhalb Jahre
gegen die Fliegen gekämpft.
Die Wände waren schwarz vor Fliegen.
Seither hat Oliver Hess eine Mission:
Er will glücklichere Schweine.
Dafür hat er im Stall
bereits einiges verändert,
aber das reicht ihm noch lange nicht.
Er will den Betrieb komplett umbauen.
Das braucht allerdings Zeit und Geld.
Es wird alles gut.
* Quietschen *
Jetzt reagiert natürlich das Mami.
Alles ist gut, alles ist gut.
Alles gut.
Als ich
zum ersten Mal in dem Stall stand,
um zu schauen, wie er aussieht,
habe ich Ueli gesagt,
dass ich hier nie arbeiten will.
Für mich war es sehr schlimm, zu se-
hen, wie die Tiere gehalten werden.
Das war die ganze Motivation,
die drei Jahre so viel zu machen,
dass wir die Chance haben ...
ähm ...
... ich sage mal, bei den Schweinen
etwas zu verändern,
das nachher artgerecht ist.
Für mich ist es eine Fabrik,
eine Tierfabrik.
Es gibt schon immer wieder Momente,
in denen ich das Gefühl habe,
dass das fast nicht
zum Aushalten ist.
V.a. in der Mast.
Ich gehe hinein und mache es,
aber ich versuche, das Gefühl,
dass das arme Tiere sind,
abzuschalten.
Sonst könnte ich es nicht machen.
Der Maststall:
Hier ist alles noch so, wie
Oliver Hess den Hof übernommen hat.
* Oli pfeift. *
Die wären jetzt im Teeniealter.
Das sind interessierte Tiere,
die wühlen möchten,
die mal rumspringen
und sehen möchten,
wie das Tageslicht aussieht.
Alles ist im erlaubten Rahmen,
auch der Vollspaltenboden.
Der wurde erst 2018 verboten.
Trotzdem sind das für Oliver Hess
schlimme Zustände,
die einen Totalumbau
erfordern würden.
Diese Schweine
sind etwa drei Monate alt,
werden mit 7 Monaten geschlachtet,
wiegen dann rund 110 kg.
Das hat mir am meisten wehgetan,
als ich das gekauft habe,
weil die Tiere wirklich
den ganzen Tag nichts zu tun haben.
Sie müssen sich in ihr Nest
versäubern, wir zwingen sie.
Die sind recht lethargisch.
Sie finden:
"Was soll ich hier den ganzen Tag?"
So warten sie, bis wir sie essen.
Das wäre, wie wenn wir am selben Ort
liegen würden:
Zunehmen würden wir auch.
Aber dieses Tier
hatte nie Muskelkater,
es hatte nie einen
richtig durchbluteten Muskel.
Man sollte sie nicht essen.
Seit Jahrtausenden dient das Schwein
dem Menschen als Fleischlieferant.
Doch für Oliver Hess
ist ein Schwein mehr.
Es hat Bedürfnisse
ähnlich denen der Wildsau.
Es möchte in der Erde wühlen,
nach Früchten suchen.
Hier ist die empfindliche Schnauze
dem Ammoniak ausgesetzt,
das aus ihrem Urin und Kot entsteht.
Sehr viele haben
Lungendeformationen,
weil sie mitten im Ammoniak sind,
in ihrem eigenen Kot.
Richtig traurig.
Hocken auf dem Beton
und warten, bis sie sterben.
Er hat sich hoch verschuldet,
um einen Hof zu kaufen,
den er radikal verändern kann.
Ende 2015 sind die Pläne
schon sehr konkret,
das Modell eines Auslaufgeheges
steht.
Die Frage ist zu beantworten:
Wie bringe ich hier 50 Tiere raus,
und wie bin ich sicher,
dass wieder alle 50 drinnen sind?
Oliver Hess sucht Investoren,
um seine Ideen zu realisieren:
2 Mi. Fr.
Interessiert sind heute
der Fleischverarbeiter Micarna
und ein Berufskollege.
Da betonieren wir 1,5 m runter,
vom Kanton ist das jetzt zugesagt.
Wir haben Kompost darin.
Es wäre natürlich super, wenn wir
den eigenen Kompost nehmen könnten.
So gäbe es wieder einen Kreislauf.
Einige Pläne sind in Mosen
bereits umgesetzt,
nämlich im Stall der Muttersäue.
Sie haben
eine abgetrennte Toilettenbucht
und im Liegebereich
Einstreu und Bodenheizung.
Ja, gib mir den Katheter.
Schon wenige Tage nach dem Absetzen
der Ferkel kommt die Brunst,
bei Schweinen auch Rausche genannt.
Der richtige Zeitpunkt
für die künstliche Besamung.
Doch die Natur
wird nicht ganz ausgesperrt,
es kommt ein echter Eber zum Einsatz:
allerdings nur mit seiner Nase.
Das Blut der Muttersäue
kommt trotzdem in Wallung,
wenn er auf seinem
ferngesteuerten Wagen vorbeifährt.
* Aufgeregtes Quietschen *
Heyey!
Feiner Bubeli.
Einmal in der Woche bekommt er
ein Schweinchen, zum belegen.
Man könnte eigentlich auch sagen:
Sofort alle Tiere freilassen
oder schlachten, nicht länger leiden
lassen, stattdessen kaufen -
warum das?
Weil auch das
das Problem nicht löst.
Wir essen jedes Jahr in der Schweiz
2,5 Mio. Schweine.
Wenn ich nun sage,
dass wir alle töten,
dann werden eben
2,5 Mio. Schweine importiert.
Wir essen so viel.
Die Lösung ist doch, schauen,
dass man an einem Ort
eine Alternative bieten kann,
um sie zu halten.
Zwei Monate später.
Oliver Hess ist unterwegs,
um für sein Projekt zu werben,
für seine Vision
von freilaufenden Wiesenschweinen,
beim Agro-Treff 2016 in Boswil.
Begrüssen wir Oli Hess.
Ich bin der Oli und gehöre
zur Rasse der Menschen,
trotz der Frisur.
Ich habe sicher ein relativ
bewegtes Leben hinter mir.
Ich durfte viele Sachen sehen.
Ich habe sicher auch
eine kindliche Neugier behalten.
Der gelernte Offsetdrucker
Oliver Hess
liebte schon immer
das fast Unmögliche.
2004 baute er
das grösste Baumhaus der Schweiz,
um einen lebenden Baum herum.
Die Eiche
kann 200-300 Jahre alt werden.
Diese Eiche kann auch wachsen.
Wir haben keine festen Verbindungen
in den Baum.
Tiere und Natur:
Davon waren Esther und Oliver Hess
bereits 2008 begeistert.
Sie bewirtschaften
eine Alp im Wallis,
ab 2009 bereits mit Baby Anouk.
Als Herdenschutzbeauftragter
des Bundes machte Oliver Hess 2010
seinem Ärger
gegenüber "10vor10" Luft.
Ich als Privatperson
schreibe rote Zahlen,
damit ich
Herdenschutz betreiben kann.
Ich habe eine junge Familie -
das geht einfach nicht.
Wirklich unzufrieden
wird Oliver Hess,
als er später auf einem Mastbetrieb
die übliche Schweinehaltung
hautnah kennenlernt.
Seitdem lässt ihn der Gedanke an
glücklichere Schweine nicht mehr los.
Ein Investor hat mich mal gefragt:
"Warum kaufst du eine Massen-
tierhaltung, um die zu verändern?"
Weil ich sie
nicht vom Büro aus verändern kann.
Wenn ich nicht in den Stiefeln stehe
und die Kruke in der Hand habe,
dann schaffe ich es nicht,
das zu verändern.
Zurück ins Luzernische,
zum Stall in Mosen, im Januar 2016.
Drinnen geht der Alltag
des Schweinemastbetriebes weiter -
für die ganze Familie.
* Quietschen *
Aber nicht zu viel.
Schau!
Nicht zu nahe!
Hier?
- Ja.
Schaffst du das?
Gut.
Sonst stehen sie drauf
und reissen es ab,
und dann gibt es einen Nabelbruch.
Das Gelenk ist noch gut.
Vielleicht erholt es sich auch noch.
Ein wenig Metam geben.
Zwei Tage alt und schon ein Unfall.
Die Muttersau hat sich,
wohl versehentlich,
auf ihr Ferkel gelegt -
300 kg tun weh.
Ich will es noch nicht töten.
Ich gebe ihm Schmerzmedikamente.
Wenn es heute Abend nicht säugt,
werde ich es töten.
Wenn es jetzt noch Muttermilch
erwischt, ist das auch gut.
* Lautes Quietschen *
Es braucht mega, mega wenig.
Das steht am Abend wieder.
Jetzt legen wir es
hier an die Wärme.
Esther Hess ist gelernte Landwirtin.
Jeden Tag ist sie im Stall,
auch jetzt noch,
wo sie im achten Monat schwanger ist.
Mit Arbeiten geht es noch?
Das geht noch,
das ist nicht so anstrengend.
Sonst mache ich nicht mehr viel,
ein wenig herumbefehlen.
Ein gutes Jahr später,
es ist Mai 2017.
Familie Hess ist gewachsen.
Und Tochter Vivijen isst das,
was hier auch der Rest der Familie
isst: Schweineschnitzel.
Und Rüebli?
- Nein. - Eins?>
Der Traum von einer
artgerechten Schweinehaltung
ist weiterhin aktuell,
inklusive Auslauf auf die Weide.
In der Computeranimation
ist alles schon Realität.
Das ist genau auf den Grundmauern
des alten Saustalles.
Dieser würde massiv höher werden,
damit wir drinnen
eine saubere Luft bekommen.
Er ist immer zugänglich.
Hier können sie die Rampe hinunter
und haben unten ein Kompostnest.
und dann kommen sie auf die Koppel.
Mit der Planung
sind wir relativ weit.
Wir stehen kurz vor Baueingabe.
Jetzt ist v.a. die zentrale Frage:
Können wir das
in der Form finanzieren?
Bisher ist von den grossen
Zukunftsplänen auf dem Hof
nichts zu sehen.
Noch immer fristen die Tiere
ihr Dasein ohne Auslauf ins Freie.
Aber Oliver Hess
ist weiter unermüdlich dran,
seine Pläne von einer besseren
Schweinehaltung umzusetzen -
gegen alle Widerstände
und mit Notfallplan.
Aber wenn Sie
jetzt aussteigen würden,
dann sehe ich nichts anderes mehr
als verkaufen.
Das Wiesenschwein per se
stirbt nicht,
aber es wird nachher
unheimlich viel schwieriger.
Trotz aller Schwierigkeiten
hat Oliver Hess Investoren gefunden,
die an seine Idee der Wiesenschweine
glauben.
Heute planen wir
ca. 6 Mio. Fr. in den Totalumbau.
Das hört sich
nach einem sehr hohen Betrag an,
aber das ist ein alter QM-Betrieb,
den müsste man sowieso umbauen.
Nebenan im Stall läuft
die Vorbereitung zum Kastrieren.
Esther Hess verabreicht
den männlichen Ferkeln
zuvor ein Schmerzmedikament.
Danach
wird die Vollnarkose eingeleitet,
das Narkosemittel
strömt aus der Maske in die Schnauze.
Ich schneide nicht gern zu tief,
sonst schneide ich den Hoden auf.
Das ist nicht
meine Lieblingsarbeit.
Es muss sein und zwar
innerhalb von 14 Tagen.
Der Grund ist eigentlich:
Wenn man sie nachher ausmästet
stinkt das Fleisch nicht.
Sie sind logischerweise
auch nicht fruchtbar,
wenn man die Hoden rausschneidet.
Guten Morgen!
Die Ferkel erholen sich schnell
von dem Eingriff,
schon nach wenigen Minuten
stehen die meisten wieder.
Und sonst
helfen die Geschwister nach.
Ein halbes Jahr später,
Dezember 2017.
Oliver Hess ist unterwegs nach Basel,
zum Hauptsitz von Coop.
Das ist sicher ein grosser Tag.
Dafür kämpfte ich
über ein Jahr lang.
Ich bin sehr erfreut, dass ich
diese Fahrt nun machen darf.
Mit Coop soll ein Vertrag
unterzeichnet werden.
Der Vertrag garantiert ihm
die Abnahme
seiner zukünftigen Wiesenschweine.
Ich weiss, was wir unterschreiben,
das wurde lange verhandelt.
Aber es ist ein wichtiger Moment.
Grüezi.
- Ciao, hoi.
Wie geht's?
- Gut und selber? - Auch, danke.
Ciao, Oli. Schön, bist du hier.
Jetzt darfst du noch.
Mit dem Grünen in dem Fall.
Das ist ein Jahr Arbeit.
Hier steckt
ein Jahr Arbeit dahinter.
Viel Arbeit.
- Für dich sogar länger.
2009 schrieb ich die ersten
Dokumente zum Thema Schwein.
Ein besonderer Moment.
- Ja, das sieht man auch.
Ich versuche,
ruhig und echt cool zu bleiben.
Du machst es gut. Du bist erfahren.
- Es geht.
Juhu.
Juhu! - Früher machte man es
nur per Handschlag.
Freut mich, Oli.
- Mich auch.
Ich freue mich aufs Projekt.
- Ich mich auch.
Es wird spannend.
- Es ist Zeit, dass wir etwas tun.
Definitiv.
Für uns ist es ein Pilotprojekt,
ein Leuchtturmprojekt.
Er hat viele innovative Ideen
dahinter.
Wiesen, Weide, Wühlen
sind Argumente,
von denen wir uns viel erhoffen.
Der Vertrag
sichert die Abnahme des Fleisches,
für Oliver Hess ein Meilenstein.
Aber etwas Entscheidendes fehlt noch.
Ich hoffe, dass der Kanton
und die Behörden gut mitmachen.
Dann hoffen wir,
dass wir im nächsten Herbst/Winter
auf dem Boden sind.
Ich freue mich
auf die ersten Schweine,
die bei uns vor dem Stall
herumspringen.
Wenige Monate später der Schock:
Seine Schweine müssen im Stall
bleiben. Sein Traum ist geplatzt.
Die Behörden
verweigern die Baugenehmigung.
Der Umbau wird vom Kanton
als Ersatzneubau eingestuft.
Darum verbiete das Raumplanungsgesetz
eine Ausweitung des Stalles,
der als Gewerbebetrieb gilt.
Das ist emotional extrem schwierig.
Auch für die Kinder,
für Esther und mich.
Es geht auch um unsere Tiere.
Ich habe meinen Tieren versprochen,
sie zu befreien.
Dass ich das jetzt nicht kann,
ist schlimm.
Der Hof ist verkauft,
ebenso das Wohnhaus nebenan.
Das Kapitel Mosen
ist für Familie Hess jetzt zu Ende.
Ja, das geht.
Man hofft immer,
v.a. auch, weil wir lange investiert
und für dieses Ziel
gearbeitet haben,
dass die Schweine
auf die Wiese dürfen.
Ja, doch. Es ist mir ...
Mir kommt es vor,
als sei alles umsonst gewesen -
die ganze Arbeit
der letzten sechs Jahre
unter diesen schlechten Bedingungen.
Doch Oliver Hess
wäre nicht Oliver Hess,
wenn er keinen Ausweg
vorgesehen hätte.
Im Vertrag mit Coop
ist eine Option offengehalten:
Das Projekt der Wiesenschweine
muss nicht zwingend in Mosen
umgesetzt werden.
Wir haben gesagt, dass wir
die Schweine befreien wollen.
Wir warten nicht noch fünf Jahre
und kämpfen für Mosen.
Wir realisieren es nun mit
einer Bauernfamilie im Entlebuch.
Wenige Monate später,
im Oktober 2018:
Der Brügghof in Schüpfheim
ist im Umbau.
Hier soll die Idee von den Wiesen-
schweinen erstmals umgesetzt werden.
Oliver Hess
ist jetzt nicht mehr Schweinemäster,
sondern eine Art Systemanbieter.
Letzter Testlauf mit den Technikern,
bevor die echten Schweine
raus dürfen.
Ich bin
die simulierte Schweinegruppe.
Viel digitale Technik
und Automatisation
sollen den Schweinen
ein artgerechtes Leben bieten.
Sensoren erkennen, ob alle Schweine
wieder im Stall sind.
Dann kann die nächste Gruppe
in den Auslauf.
* Verschieden Pieptöne *
Jede Schweinegruppe
hat ihren eigenen Rufton.
Dann wissen die Tiere, dass sie
wieder in den Stall kommen sollen,
denn es gibt Futter. So die Theorie.
Ich bin immer noch sehr angespannt,
bis ich dann weiss,
dass die Tiere das machen,
was sie machen sollten.
* Laute Piepston-Abfolge *
Jetzt müssten sie reinkommen.
Gespannt ist auch Franz Studer.
Er ist der Hofbesitzer
und will das Leben seiner jährlich
1'000 Mastschweine verbessern.
* Piepston-Abfolge *
Dann ist es so weit: Zum ersten Mal
öffnet sich für die Schweine das Tor.
Franz, du hast mutige Schweine.
Meine These stimmt nicht.
Zum ersten Mal haben sie eine grosse
Fläche mit viel Material zum Wühlen.
Jetzt!
* Fröhlich-verspielte Klänge *
Schweine im besten Teeniealter:
neugierig und quicklebendig.
Gratuliere.
- Ich gratuliere.
Super, oder?
- Ich würde schon sagen.
Es ist faszinierend,
wie sie hier herumspringen.
Und gleich beginnen,
darin herumzuwühlen.
Wiederum ein halbes Jahr später,
März 2019:
Jetzt ist auch der Auslauf
auf die Wiese fertig.
Die Schweine dürfen gruppenweise
zweimal täglich
für je 1 Std. ins Grüne.
(Esther) Es ist mega schön.
Ich wünschte, es wäre in Mosen so.
Das ist wirklich ...
sehr schön zum Zuschauen.
Der Pool reizt noch nicht.
Dagegen sind die Holzschnitzel
sehr beliebt,
da sie nach Wald riechen
und mit Maiskörnern versetzt sind.
Was gefällt dir am meisten,
wenn sie hier rumspringen?
Sie können rumwühlen
und finden leckere Sachen.
Das finde ich irgendwie schön.
Diese Ablenkung ist wichtig,
denn sonst würden die Schweine
die Wiese zerwühlen.
Diese ist zusätzlich
mit einer Matte im Boden geschützt.
Wenn sie einen Moment
im Ding rumwühlen konnten
und dann rauskönnen,
um Gras zu fressen, ist das super.
* Piepston-Abfolge *
Der Ton ruft zum Futtertrog,
die Schweine haben schnell gelernt.
Dieses System
hat Oliver Hess ausgetüftelt.
Wenn viele Bauern es übernehmen,
kann er seine Entwicklungskosten
vielleicht wieder hereinholen.
Darauf ist er dringend angewiesen.
Die von ihm gegründete Wiesenschwein
AG zahlt ihm nur einen kleinen Lohn.
Aber er verdient mit,
wenn das Fleisch unter seinem
Markennamen verkauft wird.
Oliver Hess findet, dass das Fleisch
seiner Schweine sehr gut schmecke
und hofft auf viele
ähnlich denkende Konsumenten.
Zum Wohl der Fleischesser,
aber auch der Schweine.
Darauf habe ich
zehn Jahre hingearbeitet.
Es ist super.
Wir werden
noch einen Moment brauchen,
bis sich die Schweine genau
so verhalten, wie wir es wollen.
Wir müssen sie noch mehr ablenken,
aber es ist schön.
Diese Schweine haben Schwein.
Zwar werden auch sie
in einigen Monaten geschlachtet,
aber sie hatten ein Leben in Würde.